hallo mein name ist herzlich willkommen
hier heute zu einem neuen video von mir
hören euch mal ich sitze hier nicht
alleine sondern mit jule jetzt wieder
ich habe euch bei später gesagt wir
sollten wir bilder zu senden entweder
von in welchen bekannten
persönlichkeiten oder auch von euch
selbst und juli wird mir gleich einige
von diesen bildern zeigen und ich werden
an dieser bilder das alter erraten
müssen
das war relativ gut zusammengefasst das
hier ist das erste bild ihr seht es auch
hier neben mir eingeblendet ich würde
ich mal sagen das was im bad ist und ich
glaube dass er auch alkohol trinkt da
vorne also das ist irgendwie die daten
im bierglas aus als er ist auf jeden
fall über 18 bzw 23 ist das ist harrys
teils des bistums stolz wenn ich mir das
heute so angucke ich würde sagen aber
keine ahnung 24 26 26
da ist dieses bild nicht ob der das
gleiche ob der das gleiche ist wollen
also er offenbar ist den kennt man auch
irgendwann kennt man denen ich weiß aber
auch nicht mehr das ist erst gut auf das
heißt er ist auf jeden fall über 70 ich
glaube dass es auch eben sänger aber ich
geb' euch recht auf dem schlappen
überhaupt nicht drin in dieser ganzen
musik sache da wirklich aber ich würde
jetzt einfach mal so frei schnauze
aussagen
28 tja wie viel jünger deshalb 1424 alte
orchester mit dem bart und alles
mögliche das ist der nächstes bild jetzt
sogar den manager
hey was geht ab wie kriegt man das match
eigentlich hinter - stopfen
also ich muss wirklich sagen sie hat er
das match an das macht sie natürlich
direkt sympathisch an der stelle
sie hatte zum gipfel darauf das heißt
man sieht jetzt nicht irgendwie richtig
ihre haut die ich würde allerdings mal
sagen dass sie so ich denke irgendwie
zwischen 10 und 16 also ich wirklich ich
glaube ich nicht ab 14
das nächste person höchste das mädchen
spricht ja auch per twitter ein bild
geschenkt dass sie ist cool
auf jeden fall sie hat auch wieder so
einen filter drauf ich weiß nicht dieser
filter macht das echt immer sehr schwer
also es kann halt sein dass sie älter
ist der filter macht sie jetzt jünger
oder dass sie als junges und der filter
was die eltern ich kann alles verändern
ich würde sagen
also die sieht schon relativ jung aus
und deswegen würde ich jetzt sagen dass
sie so 13 12 aber ich habe auch nichts
richtig das ist glaube ich auch ein
sänger schon mal das ist das glaube ich
oder er schaut man das schauen wir dass
18 19
er hatte geburtstag er hat deutlich
geburtstagen oder youtube oder
wahrscheinlich sind sie gleich alt sind
kein handy haben auf jeden fall beide
schon bald die sache ist halt ich mache
das immer nur an badfest werde ich
einfach keinen papa ich würde sagen dass
die irgendwie so zwischen
16.16 so das ist relativ jung ich weiß
nicht ich habe auf seiner vor ausgesucht
hat um mich zu tricksen und die tricksen
ich sag einfach mal dass die beiden 20
sind die sind 18 18 das denn die dünnen
triebe würde zum thema mit viel tempo
die dachte ich mir nicht nur einen von
den beiden ist er das ja der schwarze
haare
was hierbei ein bild wie sie früher
aussah und ich weiß nicht wie alt aber
in dieser serie ich glaube da hat er
irgendwie an weise das gespielte
irgendwie durchsagen 14 oder irgendwie
so um den dreh aber dann also um ladung
und 20 eltern älterer die sind schon 25
25 es ist ein aktuelles bild deshalb aus
wie der spiegel schreibt man die
kommentare hier wieder eine zuschauerin
leider wieder nicht finden leider wieder
mit filtern das ist das wahre filter ein
paar sekunden später die alten hasen
werden ich kann doch nie wieder nicht
richtig beurteilen wegen dem filter
halte es mit dem auto aber sie sitzt
hinten also sie fährt anscheinend nicht
weil sie so auch am handy um beim
autofahren soll beim handy sein ich
würde sagen dass die irgendwie so
zwischen irgendwie zwischen 11 und 16
die sache ist aber dass ich derzeit die
ganze seite leute eltern geschätzt
deswegen sage ich jetzt dieses 13
was ich hätte 16 jetzt gesagt ein tag
ging's richtig habe auf ihren zuschauer
von dir
ok schöne wohnung hat der darf ja eine
villa vorbei hinauf erwarten ist ja da
hingekommen geflogen ich glaube die
leute ja also man sieht hier snapshot
katzen filter auf jeden fall macht es
natürlich jetzt an der stelle auf
relativ schwierig das zu erkennen
barth bad ist auf jeden fall vorhanden
auch ganz körperbehaarung also auch
krass ist auf jeden fall ein bisschen
älter ich würde sagen
103 ist leider falsch dass erst 22 jahre
alt ihren eine männliche person
ok trägt eine brille schlau schlau also
schlau leute sind meistens ein bisschen
älter waren und es bei ihm jetzt
überhaupt nicht vorhanden
noch weniger als bei mir ja es ist
wirklich so er hatte seine brille auf er
das zimmer sieht auch so aus als würde
da noch bei seinen eltern wohnen
deswegen würde ich sagen ja ist 14 das
ist richtige alter kennt man ja nicht
was mit uns passiert ist schwer jetzt
also er hat keinen markt zu wirklich
hässlichkeit ist auf jeden fall auch
komplett vorhanden die sache ist im
hintergrund steht shop.de ich frage mich
was davor kommen sogar wien ist das echt
schwer
ich weiß nicht sagt 27 leider - - völlig
dass jetzt das nächste feld ich weiß
nicht dass die zuschauer ist oder auch
nicht bekannt
ich habe auch keine ahnung aber bei dem
was jetzt sagen wie alt das
wahrscheinlich ja ausnahmsweise wie
viele leberflecken er hat wie viele
leberflecken die sache ist bei frauen
hat man halt immer noch so merkmale die
die brust oder keine ahnung für das
komplette gesicht oder so aber wenn da
mal kein gesicht mehr ist ein
entscheidendes detail aufgefallen er hat
hier vorne an seine partei ein bändchen
und ich denke mal ist es von einem
festival und festivals darf man ja erst
wieso bist du schon wieder will es so
langweilig wird es auch von harris
besuchen wenn man mindestens 16 ist das
hat er gesagt dass er über 16 ist ich
würde ich würde sagen dass er 20 ist das
prinzip ja aber ein richtiger festival
das geld habe ich von instagram das ist
ein modell aus amerika normalerweise
wenn ich mir das bild sie gerade so
anschaue wir nicht denken so wie sie
geschminkt ist und sie ist ja so auch
relativ stylish angezogen mit dem ganzen
schmuck und so würde ich sagen dass sie
eigentlich über 23 ist auf jeden fall so
zwischen 23 und 26 möglich sagen
allerdings wenn du mir da schon raus und
sagt wo ich habe die von hintergründe
muss ist ja eigentlich irgend etwas sein
womit ich jetzt nicht rechnen das heißt
ich sage
dass sie 17 bis 18 18
na ja ich wollte er sagen ich lasse
diese 18 sitze das nächste es auch makel
ich weiß nicht geschafft wenige minuten
später sie trägt eine relativ knappe
tasche glaube ich habe noch ein relativ
kurzes kleid und sie ist halt bei einer
gala und ich glaube wenn man afghanistan
gallen
das ist da werden ja jetzt nicht
irgendwelche 15 16 jährigen mädels
eingeladen die irgendwie ein bisschen
auf instagram paar follower haben oder
so deswegen würde ich sagen dass sie
schon so easy sage ich mal 22
nein das ist immer so packen das ist das
letzte bild das letzte das ist eine
sängerin die sängerin
dies heißt die ich glaube die plätze ein
bisschen mit ihrem mit ihren brüsten so
ein bisschen und drückte ihren arm so
leicht gegen aber ich baue ich habe auch
hier wieder überhaupt keine ahnung ich
würde eigentlich sagen wenn ich dir
jetzt so sehr so hin keine ahnung so 31
21 würde ich sagen aber wenn du das hat
schon so raussuchen
sängerin
davon würde ich sagen dass sie 18 ist 16
jahre
16.16 molly romania geboren 22 mai 2001
was was 16
das war für sie auch vom video meine
damen und herren wenn es euch gefallen
hat das gerne man leiht daran nehmen
wollte dass ich öfter so alter erraten
vielleicht nicht jetzt unbedingt viel
mehr von zuschauern von mir sondern
vielleicht mal von anderen youtube aus
amerika irgendwie so dann schreibt
würden gerne die kommentare schreibt mir
auch die kommentare ob ihr riverdale
guckt weil ich suche gerade eine neue
serie das riverdale oder strange things
oder irgendwie sowas ist heute etwas
anderes setting was ihr hier schon seht
in meinem video einfach weil es gerade
schon relativ dunkel draußen ist und ich
aber trotzdem bisschen licht braucht
euch das video um eine soft boxen
ja das blendet mir irgendwie zu kraft
ich habe mir so ein rief gewachsen war
gesteht er zwei lokführer aber steht er
dennoch herr zwei solid oder definitiv
nein das was ihr vom video das war es
jetzt hier vom video hier können
jetzt jemanden kanal abonnieren oder
hier unten meinen job ausschenken jetzt
findet ihr zwei andere videos und wenn
ihr schon abonnent seid könnt ihr auf
die glocke klicken dann bekommen die
benachrichtigungen